Carroll is with us in Oklahoma City
Carol what are you grateful for hi Dave
I'm I'm really grateful and I'm so
thankful for the grace of God toward me
and that he never gives up on me I mean
even though all my failures he keeps
he's still there he's consistent and
then I'm thankful for my daughter so
that there are Christian young ladies
and they both use your envelope
Knesset's and that two of them aren't
that pretty all right very cool
yeah grace is ridiculous it doesn't even
make sense I would have given up on me a
long time oh yeah how can I hope today
well first of all I'm very honored to be
speaking I can't believe that I'm
talking to you I called because I needed
help and I'm talking to you now so I'll
make it better I have it written down
and my question is should I use Freedom
Debt Relief or should I try to settle
myself with my creditors I am in a lot
of debt
I've made a bad lot of bad choices and
I'm a compulsive gambler and so I am
recovering from that how long has it
been since you've gambled um it's been I
mean recent recently so are you in
Gamblers Anonymous I'm in generous
anonymous and then there's a thing in my
church and how long have you been doing
those things I've been doing those
things like the first time I did it was
like four years ago and then I was
almost three years
good then my husband decided he was
going to leave and divorce which is I
still chose to go back and I relapsed
and lashes so he left when he left when
you relapsed are you relaxed when he
left no I relapsed with you left okay
and how long ago and so how big a hole
did you dig the second time how much
debt have you got um I have if you
include you know a why live in a mobile
home and and I owe like $18,000 on that
but the risk if you can't lose all my
debt totally
fifty-five thousand how much of that's
credit cards 27 thousand is in credit
cards and but then I have like forty
seven hundred dollars I faith nor 8 May
16 about 2500 dollars in the stupid
payday loans and I have 1700 or 17,000
in my student loans and 2500 dollars in
my youngest daughter's parents well and
how much what is your intent my income I
my income is twenty five hundred seventy
two dollars a month but my daughter my
oldest one she's almost 22 she gives me
two hundred eighty dollars a month
toward part of the bills and her
cellphone bill she lives with you
she was yes okay okay well what you're
going to end up doing is a couple things
one is the problems you've got
financially are the symptoms they're not
problems they're symptoms of the other
things that have been going on in your
life you know that exactly and so
there's no way to turn this around
unless you deal with the gambling issue
and you're in the process of doing that
and so I'm happy for ya that's good
stuff
and you know you're you back on the
wagon again okay now the then what we're
going to do is we're gonna put the
student loan and hardship deferral
oh I okay my student loan actually I do
that okay good
that's first thing that's first thing
and then you're going to take care of
your four walls before you do anything
now the four walls are food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities do
you have a car payment yes
how much do in your car um I owe about
four thousand okay you pay ya we pay
your car payment and your and your
trailer payment before you pay anything
and you buy food and you buy lights
before you do anything you take care of
the basic house
old necessities before we talk about
paying payday lenders before we talk
about credit cards and before we talk
about student loans and before we talk
about anything okay so food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities
and you've got enough to do those things
your income is enough to cover those
things you don't have enough income to
cover everything else then after you
take care of those things and so
something's going to go somebody's going
to go crying and it's going to be the
credit cards the credit cards are going
to be who doesn't get paid if anybody
doesn't get paid you pay the other stuff
first you got to get rid of these payday
lenders as fast as you possibly can and
you never set foot in those freaking
places again do you hear me yes sir
they're ripping your head off you know
that yeah oh yeah they are yeah they're
horrible and so you know right as soon
as I get desperate when I get stupid and
that's what happened there you were
desperate you got stupid yeah and I do
the same thing so you're going to be
okay you gonna make it you're turning
your life around I'm proud of you so you
so first thing we're going to do is take
care of you that's food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities okay that
make sense okay and we're going to take
care of the payday lenders you got the
student loan on hardship deferral and
the other little $2,500 one what was
that oh my god she's a freshman at Emory
oh you got the student loan thing okay
see if you can get that put on hardship
deferral too are you even paying on it
right now no I haven't even if she's in
if she's in school it probably doesn't
even have a payment so it's sitting
there good so we get the payday lenders
cleaned out and then we do the best we
can do towards the credit cards pick out
a few of them you're going to keep alive
and the rest of them let them die okay
and then you can go back then later you
can go back and settle with them when
you get your income up and get this mess
cleaned up okay that's why that's why
that's what I'm trying to do I mean I
know if that Freedom Debt Relief that's
what they want no no you stay away from
those people you don't need them okay
because you can't pay right now anyway
right exactly by the time you take care
of you and you clear these payday
lenders you're not going to have
anything left for credit cards today and
later on you're not going to have enough
left to pay them all
anyway right because they're at the
bottom of the list so you're going to
come back to them later and you don't
need to set up a payment plan through
some debt con solid ation process don't
do that crap and just let them die right
now because it's all you can do now then
you have got to commit to taking care of
Carol yeah it means you don't miss a ga
meeting and you don't miss the group at
your church you're there every time okay
because it's your only shot at having an
awesome future yes yeah and Here I am
have you heard of Lending Club I did
that too
oh Lord yeah yes yeah yeah and passed up
one up have you I know I got it why you
got lines for every one of them girl hey
you want have you been through Financial
Peace University yet no no my daughter I
need you I need you to go through
Financial Peace University will be part
of your financial Ealing while GA and
your church helps you with the healing
of your heart okay yep all right you
hold on and Kelly I'll pick up we'll get
you signed up for that